after dominating the first two seasons
of the corporate chess league edward
jones was shocked by enterprise in the
2020 finals by john boyer's last second
checkmate in an overtime thriller
undeterred edward jones reclaimed their
fame and got their name back on the
board in the spring 2021 season now it's
the fall 2021 season the scores have
been reset to zero will edward jones
dynasty reign on or will a new
powerhouse emerge find out
now
well like mike said the time is now
welcome back everybody to the 2021 fall
season of the corporate chess league my
name is caleb denby and as you just
relived the excitement of the playoffs
of last season we're looking forward to
more excitement this season for sure
it's going to be a great season but why
don't we take a look at some of the
details here as we get into the format
for the league of course each season is
12 weeks long with two games played each
week all the matches are played on
thursday nights on chess.com we're
keeping it virtual for this season for
now we might do some hybrid events a
little bit later on in the season but
still keeping it virtual tonight uh
players play four total games each night
it takes about two hours and the time
control for each game is going to be 10
minutes per side with no increment and
no delay that's how you end up with
those crazy time scrambles like we saw
in the intro
um of course the scoring for everything
is a little bit complicated you get 20
points for winning your team's match and
you get one extra point per
board point so if you win your game
individually but your team loses your
team still gets one point for that
and speaking of teams who's playing this
year let's take a look we have worldwide
technology enterprise edward jones bayer
ascension and dardy all making a return
to the corporate chess league now thus
far edward jones has been the team to
beat the dominant team they reclaimed
their first place spot at the end of
last season but enterprise definitely
always gives them a run for their money
so what's going to happen this year will
it be another enterprise edward jones
showdown or will one of these other
teams prove to be a dark horse and take
home the gold for themselves
speaking of taking home the gold what is
it that these teams are playing for the
prizes this season is what everybody
wants to know the winning team will be
declared the 2021 corporate chess league
champions they also are gonna get their
name engraved on that very nice wooden
board that mike was holding up earlier
and they will be in possession of that
board until the next season the winning
team also gets some free training a
two-hour strategy session with the
resident grand master of the st louis
chess club that way they come back even
stronger the following year
of course as i said i'm caleb i will be
hosting tonight and i will be providing
commentary all over all of the action
going on on chess.com i want to say
hello to all the viewers out there in
the youtube chat hello to njf and
ederson uh who says viva argentina so
international viewers already it's going
to be a really exciting event this uh
coming up here tonight especially
because we have some very exciting
pairings who's playing who well we have
two rounds here tonight in round one
edward jones your reigning champions
will take on worldwide technology
enterprise your reigning runner-ups i
guess will be taking on bayer and
ascension is going to be taking on a
dardy now that's round one but i want to
uh already give you a sneak peek at
round two because in round two we're
going to have a big rematch between
edward jones and enterprise you know i
don't want to say there's bad blood
between these teams but it is always a
close close fight whenever these two
teams play each other so definitely
looking forward to that one now in round
one i think we're going to mostly keep
an eye on the ascension doherty match
but for now we are waiting for the games
to get rocking and rolling let's see if
the players are coming online yet over
on chess.com
um looks like they are still connecting
uh the scheduled start time is in just
one minute so hopefully they can get
underway soon but until then how's it
going chat yes hello hello to iqi hello
to muhammad hello to carlos carlos who
asked me to say hello to brazil so hello
anyone else watching from brazil and
hello uh from greece someone is saying
hello so hello to anthonis
um in the meantime here still trying to
pull up some games once they get going
but we
will await patiently
all right looks like gilmore's online
for ascension let's see if uh
maurice is online not yet oak ave
yeah still waiting a lot of the players
still getting connected here it does
take some time to get these rounds
underway
and wow we're really it's a global
audience tonight uh fidel from spain
texas joe how can we forget about texas
joe
and uh and everybody else out there as
well
and wow uh
huge developments happening on my
pairing spreadsheet as i speak edward
jones players are dropping like flies uh
it looks like some of them maybe had to
pull out at the last second here they
are are being removed from the
spreadsheet so not good news for edward
jones but we'll see if they can uh keep
it together here for their uh their big
matchups
in the meantime why don't i give you a
quick rundown of some of the players on
edward jones so i'm looking at
actually a new player who i
did not recognize justini
linguini will be board one for edward
jones tonight and that is definitely a
new name of course vishal barawaj was
the hero for edward jones last time but
uh looks like he might not be able to
play tonight of course edward jones also
fielding alex curford alex the league
commissioner who helps us organize all
these things we're definitely going to
be keeping an eye on his games fishers
of men also a regular on the edward
jones squad andy mckess another new
player i believe who i have not had the
pleasure of following too many of his
games
of course in round one they're up
against worldwide technology as we said
and i'm seeing some regulars over there
as well of course i always like to root
for dv dutch he has made a a good habit
of showing up to some of my classes and
lectures throughout
the year so we'll see if that special
instruction is gonna pay off for him
and as we continue on here we're still
looking for those games to get started
more of the players are coming online
but uh none of them
in their games yet
so we shall continue waiting who else we
got of course chess hulky for enterprise
is always a regular
and i believe the highest rated player
in the event kamikaze knight is making a
return for enterprise sort of a hero for
the enterprise team last season but
unfortunately was not able to get it
done at the very very end with
edward jones once again taking home the
gold moneyballin always a pleasure to
watch and kenjalum who i think maybe
knew that name is not ringing too many
bells for me
over on the bayer side we've got vindy
playing incline bear
just bear probably and m nmc gin
not a lot of names i'm recognizing
anymore i think these these are some new
players we'll definitely have to keep an
eye on
ascension as always has frank tan and s
gilmore and oak ave who could forget oak
ave i seem to remember some very uh
exciting games that came down to uh to
oak ave's board okav i think the lowest
rated player on the ascension squad but
was definitely able to come through with
some clutch victories in last year's
season
okay
so just to reiterate uh some things the
time controls tonight are going to be 10
minutes with a zero second increment
um
and
it should be should be a lot of fun
okay
still looking for those games to get
underway here i get the feeling that
some of these last minute dropouts might
have caused some delays for us but
hopefully we do get underway before too
long here
uh and hello steve sweet man in the chat
we're always rooting for the wonderful
team over at worldwide technology
um and correct me if i'm wrong sweetman
but
mjc3801 it might just be that the name
is not super memorable to me but i think
that might be a new board one uh heading
the worldwide technology team definitely
something to keep an eye on
hello to brian ketterin who i think
might be playing
maybe not i don't know why that name
sounded so familiar
but
okay still trying to get a hold of some
of these players over here on chess.com
it looks like more and more are coming
online
but
still no games
let's see is chess hulky online yet oh
alex kurford is online our league
commissioner and hopefully before too
much longer we get these games going i'm
really ready to start talking about some
chess
hello to leandro another from brazil wow
i never realized how many uh
just how far
chess is is spreading with these little
broadcasts that we do
okay who else we got who else we got
m s
t a d t e r what a weird name n s tadter
i'm not gonna have a fun time
pronouncing that all night
darty is representing of course legos uh
with a user called i love legos 2.
and of course he should have said i love
lego bricks ah and here now you can see
what i'm looking at too this is our
magical pairing spreadsheet um and as
you can see some controversy on the
edward jones team i actually spoke with
alex before the broadcast tonight and he
let me know that unfortunately they had
to do some roster changes at the last
minute seems like uh their team had a
lot going on tonight so we'll see if
they can still pull together with their
four super strong players remaining
and of course down here i was shouting
out i love legos too so these are your
round one matchups once again of course
when there are extra players on each
team they still get to play some chess
but it just does not contribute to their
match score however they still are
playing for points if they win each win
does add to their grand prix point total
of course that's what the ultimate goal
is you do well in the regular season in
the grand prix you qualify for the
playoffs and then you get to take home
that trophy
why don't we take a peek over round two
as well this is what i was really
highlighting earlier we have vishal
who was the hero last season unable to
play tonight it looks like so the
mystery justini linguini will be heading
up edward jones against enterprise
that's uh that rematch of the ages that
everyone is looking forward to here
will edward jones be able to prove
dominance once again or will enterprise
dethrone the champions
worldwide technology is also going to be
taking on darty a little bit later on
with ascension against bayer to round
out the group
so i want to hear from you guys in the
chat are there any teams you're looking
forward to uh to watching i'm looking
forward definitely to that edward jones
enterprise matchup and round one i think
i am going to focus on ascension dhardi
now i don't want to give away too much
but i believe the ceo of doherty is an
avid chess fan these days i think his
name is ron i had the pleasure of
talking to him once or twice
and so when the head of your company is
taking an interest in chess you know i
expect that the team is going to be
following suit here so we'll see if
they've been working hard over the long
offseason between these uh leagues
and just to
it just goes to show it looks like uh
for the most part the dardy team's all
here they all seem to be online
so
still
waiting for those games to get underway
but uh every member of the darharti team
is on chess.com online
and now
we just need some chess games we really
do just need some chess games
okay
so
as we continue to wait
uh how's it going in the chat room how
is it going lots of interesting like
emojis i didn't know youtube had all
these cool uh little emojis going on
like this little waving guy very
interesting very interesting stuff
um in the meantime i guess i'll talk oh
wait a second wait a second that's a
chess game i'm looking at a chess game
all right looks like the board one
match-up between ascension and dougherty
uh of course frankie tan playing for
ascension in sea cell playing for dardy
has gotten underway so hopefully the
rest of those games are going to start
to follow suit here but this i believe
is our first game of the night and what
an interesting one as well we have
ourselves a sicilian
um
and white's making a really interesting
choice here to develop this bishop out
to c4 so early now i'm not a sicilian
aficionado but sometimes you start to
regret this because this bishop can
really get kicked around
once black is going to break in the
center or on the queen's side with these
type of pawn pushes this bishop is going
to have to move again and it might end
up being a little bit of a waste of time
these players though not pausing for
anything we saw a quick d4 a quick
capture on d4 and just no time is being
wasted i wonder if this is just all you
know super strong theory
i might be getting outclassed here by
frank tan
and c cell
um to my eyes though it really looks
like something might be going wrong with
this bishop on on c4 it's a loose piece
it's not defended it's also opposite
this queen on c7 if black or i'm sorry
if white wherever uh if black were ever
to make a good discovery with this
knight hitting this bishop then he's
really gonna have some big issues now
though we see bishop back to d3
um white securing this bishop on a more
safe square
and once again
uh
more games are getting underway i'm
looking here we've got justini linguine
has made his official appearance
and while we pull up some of those games
let's continue seeing who we've got
uh
playing so far oh and now the games are
just flowing in everybody is playing
let's get chess hulky followed let's get
kamikaze knight followed
and we'll have a plenty of action to go
over here
those players are amateurs yes so not
professionals in the chess world but
professionals in the business world is
what we like to say and yet we've got
the game back up for you so things are
really uh moving quite quickly here i
know last season we had a lot of games
being decided on the clock so maybe
players have you know heeded my warnings
finally better to have a bad position in
more time than a good position and no
time at all
although we do see frank now jumping in
with 96 this is a pretty nasty fork uh
you know i'm not sure i would want to
have black's position anymore looks like
frank up to a significant advantage why
don't we take a look at some of the
other boards in this ascension doherty
match up i am looking for oak ave down
here oak have against m s t or m stat
i don't know
and seemingly opposite the frank tan
game these players are moving at a
snail's pace only four moves on the
board you see a really early knight c6
here by emstadter running into d5 and
now f4
and white's just trying to come after
this knight use all these extra free
tempe's hitting the knight to get a big
strong center and try to prove to black
you know you're not going to have as
much space you're going to have a really
tough time bringing your pieces into the
game if i control all this space
but then we actually see white getting a
little bit overzealous maybe already
going with f5 as well
and there is such a thing as pushing the
pawns too far black now is going to try
to claim that these pawns are
overextended and actually jump back in
to some of those squares that these
white pawns have left behind f5
definitely not my move of choice now
black has this strong knight over here
on e5 it's going to be able to develop
naturally with knight f6 behind it
and break up these pawns pretty directly
with a move like e6 or even c6 and yes
c6 is emstadter's choice
off to a good start for the player who
seems to be a little bit
outraged um who else are we looking for
we are looking for i love legos 2
against maurice gp uh in this case
uh team lego is team docherty and
maurice is playing for ascension of
course
and what's going on in this game it
looks like a little bit of a fork a
little bit of a double attack of course
this is one of the most common tactics
that uh
slightly lower level players run into
quite a bit you want to put all your
pieces in the center but when you do so
sometimes they're just awkwardly placed
and one little pawn can cause a lot of
damage attacking both knight and bishop
legos can i have a difficult time saving
both pieces going to be going down a
piece here but worse than that legos is
also in the think tank spending all of
their time here trying to uh to figure
it out and yeah not good to be down on
the clock with a bad position once again
the clock is going to be very very
important mark my words the clock is
all
okay with that why don't we try to
find this s gilmore game against des
rats this is the last game in the
matchup between ascension and dhardi of
course s gilmore playing for ascension
and d or des des rats des rat playing
for darty so let's see what's going on
here
once again ascension with the rating
advantage here and uh seemingly a pretty
good position white controlling the
center desert going for more of a modern
approach developing these bishops out to
their fianchettoed squares and only
later going after the center with a
break like e5
you know white uh for the most part here
just staying super calm staying uh
more conservative only going for this d4
pawn not going for any type of early e4
breaks against this dutch setup
and yet another interesting game
and as i was saying that the clock is
going to be everything we already have a
result we already have a result here so
c cell
may be taking that advice a little bit
too drastically we saw of course this
knight land on e6 attacking the queen
and the rook giving c cell the
disadvantage here
so he kept up the the pressure on the
clock playing
nearly instantly for the rest of this
game um however instantly doesn't mean
well knight b6 just loses this knights
and then uh a little bit afterwards here
we're gonna see disaster strike pawn
takes on c4 queen takes on c4
and then sea salt just moving too
quickly does not see the threat one
second to play the move rook c8 and then
the queen falls and c cell has to resign
so maybe you know a little bit too
quickly their c cell it does it does
take some time to play these chess games
uh with that being said let's head back
over to that board 2 matchup between
ascension and dardy we're looking at s
gilmore against his rat and that e4
break actually did come and ask gilmore
showing some real understanding of these
positions he has placed his pieces well
in the center of the board and now he is
opening up a file for his rook to get
some activity and join the game this is
uh some really good early middle game
play and i really am not a fan of this
move knight c6 by uh desrat i think here
you know maybe you can claim that white
was just a little bit too quick breaking
with e4 playing something like pawn
takes on e4
um i think would have given uh white a
lot more trouble if white takes this
back then black's going to be able to
capture and you might have an attack
on this bishop on f4 could have actually
been some real problems for gilmore
that's why we always say loose pieces
drop off you want to make sure your
pieces are safe and sound before going
for these kinds of breaks so e4 but then
black does not take allowing white to
capture on f5 now after knight h5
white simply moves the bishop and
white's going to have some really nice
pressure down this e file here black is
going to be getting this pawn back we're
going to even consider taking here
although for the moment that might be a
little bit risky due to bishop c4
tactics
but yeah definitely white for choice
with this nice pressure down the e file
and wow this is a bold move by black
he's not going to uh to take it lying
down as they say he goes h6 trying to
drive this bishop back
but i i have to wonder if this is the
right approach making all these
light-squared weaknesses around the king
i think i think black might be playing
with some fire here
i kind of suspect the idea is to go g5
and actually g4 trying to harass this
knight and take away more defenders of
this d4 pawn and that's what we're
seeing develop but
i mean i have to wonder my my sense my
my bad my spider sense my spider sense
is tingling bad sense i don't know
whichever superhero has the sixth sense
that's the one that's tingling right now
can white play some sacrifices and go
after this black king just very directly
oh and we have a worldwide technology
fan in the chat
so speaking of that let's see if we can
check in on one or two of the worldwide
technology games speaking of
huge results on board one between edward
jones and worldwide technology the
newcomer justini linguini seems to not
be having the easy ride he might have
hoped for as board one on edward jones
facing off against dv dutch whose rating
by the way definitely is not accurate i
know this guy is much stronger than
1070.
um
dv dutch of course who attends some of
my classes i haven't seen him in a while
though so hopefully he'll come back
continuous chess training but we have a
benko gambit in this game then
seems to develop along fairly normal
lines this interesting move rook a6 is
actually a nice idea that helps black
slide the rest of the major pieces over
in order to continue attacking on the
queen side getting that queen side
counter play and yeah we do actually see
queen a8 by uh
i was gonna say david it's his real name
by dv dutch
then he rebounds this knight to e5 and
this is just classy stuff this is a
classy benko
although i i have to say
you know this e6 move is is always a
little bit scary i think it's perfectly
fine here at the rook on a6 well placed
to help defend this pawn on d6 but you
do have to be cautious whenever you play
this pawn break
we get to trade on e5 white expanding
with f4
and then oh a very weird trade on c3
definitely don't know how i feel about
that one
but everything seemed to be under
control dv dutch gets his pawn back and
then actually starts just collecting the
pieces here up in exchange
and pushes his past pawn for victory and
that's going to be a victory for
dv dutch
now of course i want to point out that
the these players do not just play only
one game with each other
these are two game long matches so each
player is going to get a chance for
revenge
in their second game speaking of a
chance for revenge it looks like this
first game between oak ave and m statter
did not end well for m statter i was
praising his opening play i believed but
things went wrong uh very very quickly
well wasn't so much praising his as
questioning oak apps you know early
pressure on these super advanced pawns
can be kind of scary but yeah definitely
now's not the time to back down with
your pieces like this and then with the
spatial advantage we see an unfortunate
blender here and then the light squares
just fell apart check
and then uh oh no the queen falls
the rook falls in and checkmate and just
20 moves so not a good start for ems
doctor now let's see what he can do
against oak hive in game two and uh it
looks like disaster has already struck
he starts with the grub the fan favorite
grub but of course the grob is always
going to come with some very serious
risks so g4 e4
takes takes and then yeah this rook is
just just hanging on h1 so rough start
for m starter oak abs scoring some uh
very nice points for ascension
and
uh i think that's going to be the story
of that match ascension just seems to
have that raiding edge on most boards
definitely an uphill battle for darty to
to catch up
uh in the meantime let's see who else is
is playing as we take a look around here
let's see if i can pull up
our
lovely commissioner's game let's see how
alex is doing
uh if i close one or two of these
he should be able to
get pulled up here
there he is alex kurford uh with the
white pieces and they still seem to be
in round one now alex and sweet man i
think are no strangers i seem to
remember them playing at least a few
games in previous seasons
so let's see how this uh interesting
battle is shaping up here
and boy it is a very interesting
position we have
you know black sporting this very nice
protected pass pawn on e4 and i say that
it's no longer protected but it's
becoming more passed by the second e2 e1
is the idea will he be able to make it
all the way down the board or will alex
be able to catch this pawn we shall see
in the meantime of course you know
white's position isn't totally dead by
any means he has this f pawn in exchange
and you might see some kind of king side
push a little bit later on with that
being said
i think black might have a very
interesting move here that could put
alex under the gun
and we'll see if he finds it we'll we'll
stick on this for just a moment and he
does not find it bishop b3 by no means
is a bad move but i think
i think this was the idea if you simply
go here there's no way to stop this pawn
from uh queening
and white's gonna have to give up the
bishop so alex definitely needs to find
some way either this move or this move
just some way to stop that bishop idea
of course
now he does it with with a third idea g3
just defending the square directly
but uh still going to be a very
interesting game black now is has
captured more than one pawn over here on
the queen side but white's probably
going to be able to collect on c on e2
and if white can stop this b pawn can
get his own pawns rolling maybe alex is
in there with a shout so interesting
interesting game
for worldwide technology against sweet
man uh or sorry sweet man four world
techno worldwide technology against
edward jones and as i'm looking at the
the scores coming in here it looks like
uh
a fairly level match between edward
jones and worldwide technology
but with those last second dropouts it
looks like they're being counted as
double forfeits so bad news for edward
jones if that is the case if they are
dealing with three
uh three forfeits uh in their matches
that's that's not gonna be ideal gonna
be a
you know definitely an uphill battle for
them in this matchup then
in the meantime let's get back to our
main matchup here ascension versus
dhardi we've got c cell versus frank tan
on board one and i'm glad to see see
cell taking a little bit more time in
this game of course in round one c cell
blitzed his way out to a losing position
not spending
really any time at all but uh in this
case taking a little bit more time and i
think it's it's working out for him a
little bit he's got a very interesting
position double edged to be sure
but uh so far looks like neither side
has hung any pieces which means this
game is uh this game is a success in my
book
trent's asking who are these players not
sure what the corporate chess league is
so of course this is our fall season for
the corporate chess league it is an
event for saint louis organizations and
corporations to uh test their medal over
the chessboard
so everyone you see playing here tonight
represents uh a saint louis company and
is uh fighting for their company uh for
for their name for their recognition as
strong chess players
okay we get queen back to c7 now
and yeah i think frank tan is is making
a lot of good points here he's saying
yeah i'm going to continue my pawn push
on the queen side at the same time you
know your pawns over here might actually
be a little bit vulnerable if you can't
prove it right away
so we definitely need to see some active
play
by c cell or else this game could start
turning very very quickly and yeah
rookie one these moves just seem a
little bit slow to me i think definitely
we had to see a move like e6 on the last
turn because now after something like b5
the pieces just gets you know just get
swatted away for white all the attackers
start retreating and the pawn storm
keeps keeps coming that being said we
don't see b5 by frank i think b5
definitely the best move in that
position instead we get ricky eight and
just feels like both players are are
focusing on sort of the wrong thing now
you know why do we care so much about
attacking this e pawn one time we should
be caring about uh launching these pawns
down the board and checkmating the white
king and the black king
um but okay after knight d3
you know it's not too late for frank
frank can definitely still go for ideas
like pawn to b5 and we do see it
happening here
however it's it's a little bit less
convincing than it was in the previous
position because now this bishop's just
gonna slide into d5 maybe
maybe white can consider capturing on c5
and uh it's it's gonna be an interesting
battle to be sure
okay checking back in let's do another
look around the rest of the matchups
here between ascension and dardy we've
got s gilmore against des rats
looks quite good for s gilmart an extra
queen is an extra queen this move should
lead to checkmate quite shortly if black
wants to take
um then we can come over with this rook
check check checkmate and that'll be the
end of that
instead we see uh h3 a good move because
actually
i should highlight here i just did not
even look at the placement of black's
remaining major piece but if you were to
play f6 you actually get a pretty cold
shower in the form of rook c1 which
would have been back rank mate so h3 the
responsible move to prevent that
background checkmate and then uh s
gilmore does get the job done
okay now those players are set to begin
their second game of the round in the
meantime let's check back in on board 3
which is of course maurice against i
love legos 2. i get the feeling this is
one of the few remaining games
uh from game one of the round
and unfortunately for legos
legos down on the clock and down on the
board looks like they're trying to go
for some stalemate ideas perhaps
sacrificing all their remaining pieces
and then trying to make it so their king
has no remaining legal moves but with
just a second on the clock it's not even
going to matter white doesn't even need
to make a queen because the clock will
do the check meeting for you ah and then
a nice ad on the screen
okay continuing on uh let's check board
four
uh oh and yeah board four going about as
expected after seeing the opening the
grub not a very good opening to be
honest with you guys it does come with a
lot of downsides and those downsides
once again became very evident very
early on in this game weakening these
light squares and then unfortunately for
mstatter just did not see the attack on
the rook or at least did not see how to
prevent it black goes up a rook and now
i i believe has checkmate in one
although notably that move would be
stalemate this would be stalemate but no
no such stalemate for m statter
oak ave knows better and just plays the
checkmate in one
so correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
that that win is actually securing a
victory in the match for ascension over
dardy it was a clean sweep in the first
game uh and now
with that first win in the second game
it looks like ascension's lead is now
insurmountable over dardy so i
am going to
start focusing
on a different match then so why don't
we check in see how enterprise is doing
uh against
uh who are they playing against bayer
so let's see if i can
follow
uh chess hulky here we go chess holkey
playing for enterprise
as always
a pleasure to watch his games we've got
an interesting position here it looks
like chess holkey off to a good start in
the first game of his matchup
uh has a full point there and oh
that last move doesn't look like a
winner to me looks like this knight on
c6 is being left in the dust
not ideal for uh incline bear for bayer
okay looks like chest lockie has this
one under control why don't we check in
on the highest rate of player in the
event kamikaze knight sporting that
clean that slick 2200 rating
um he's up against vindy
whose rating may only be 1400 but i
remember he's uh quite the tough
customer in these events so definitely
another interesting game
we see vindy breaking in the center
pretty early on it's a little bit of a
strange opening with one d3 i wonder if
this was on purpose or if this was
potentially uh just just a mouse slip d3
and then we see vindy going for an e4
break a very uncommon opening here for
white but we'll see how it works out for
him
we'll see how it works out
and then questions from the chat do you
think the benodi defense is as boring as
i think it is i think it's quite
interesting actually but known as a very
interesting opening
carlos likes the gamuts yeah but the
grub
there are better ways to have fun in
your chess games than by playing the
grub you know there's just there's
better ways to do it
better ways to do it
okay well this game off to a fairly slow
start it looks like both sides are
taking their time since it is such an
uncommon opening
let's see how moneyballin is doing
oh and it looks like moneyballin is
actually complete
his games for the round are complete
he's split with his opponent one-to-one
um and just for clarity here i'm looking
at the scores it looks like enterprise
also has already scored four points in
their match so if they can just get a
half point from any of the remaining
games they will also secure victory in
their match over bayer
that being said let's check in on
somebody new kendalum is not a name i
recognize
and
it's not a good wait no it is a good
position pendulum has black here we'll
see if they uh
are well equipped to do the king and
queen checkmate
it looks like some some strange
technique is going on here some strange
check technique approaching from
opposite sides with the queen and the
king
will kendalum be able to find the main
point you want to block this king off on
the edge of the board you don't want to
try to checkmate in the middle of the
board and oh boy i sense um
i sense a stalemate coming everybody i
sense a still mate coming oh will it be
a stalemate or is kendalum a super
genius that's checkmate that's checkmate
not the most orthodox way of forcing
checkmate with the king and the queen
but you can't argue with results you
can't argue with the results so
kendallum is the hero for enterprise
here
with that point enterprise has
officially won their match against bayer
in the meantime i think that is the
match is decided uh of course the
remaining games still have a big impact
over our total standings
because
even after you win the match when you
win the match you get 20 points towards
the grand prix but you also get points
for your each individual boards so if a
team wins eight to nothing then they
actually get 28 points towards the grand
prix and if a team wins five to three
then they only get 25 points not other
team they still get three points so each
and every game remains important
uh towards those grand prix standings
which is really what matters at the end
of the day
so checking in here it looks like we
don't have too much more development in
this game between vindy and kamikaze
knight vindi really taking it slow it
makes me think that vindy might not be
as familiar with the opening that he
chose here maybe this move 1d3 was in
fact just just a slip it doesn't look
like vindy's super confident with what's
going on
we see this interesting idea knight h5
this has actually appeared in a couple
of the games that we took a look at so
far today
um and it's just an idea whenever you
bring a bishop out like this you know
your bishop looks really active sitting
on a square like f4 or g5
but sometimes bishops are actually quite
good on their starting squares you know
you'll you'll oftentimes see maybe like
a bishop drop back to f1 even or a
bishop staying on c1 or c8 for a long
long time and it might seem like hey
what are they doing why aren't they
developing they're bishops but whenever
you bring the bishops out too early they
sometimes you know become targets
they're easy to kick around they're long
range pieces and they can be kicked
around by short range pieces when they
are so close to them this pawn now
hitting the bishop the bishop with only
the g5 square left to go to we might
actually see black going for some type
of expansion over here on the king's
side just to continue
the relentless harassment of the
star-squared bishop somebody ought to
put a stop to this
um and yeah as always if you're just
joining the chat thank you so much for
watching this is the start of our fall
season of the corporate chess league we
are looking at games between uh members
of local st louis corporations all
fighting for their name on the uh
the trophy chessboard and there they are
the corporations competing tonight once
again worldwide technology enterprise
ascension edward jones bayer and dardy
business solutions
so that's who's playing here tonight
and it's looking like uh we we are
getting some clarity here in all of our
matches edward jones actually had four
players drop out it looks like right at
the last minute so they were
saddled with four forfeits in their
match-up against worldwide technology
not i don't even think they could
mathematically overcome that deficit
even if they won all of their games
so rough start for them
and on the other matchups our main
matchup was this one between ascension
and dardy and it looks like ascension
has clinched the match victory in that
but let's stick with them here let's see
how desrat and s gilmore are doing in uh
their second game
so desrat hoping to improve over that
first game loss but actually you know
looking at this position here it looks
like black is is already firmly in
control we we have this night retreating
attacking this bishop unfortunately this
knight is just attacked twice it's
unable to move out of the way because if
it moves out of the way
then you get checkmated so that's why we
see
desert just going you know kind of wild
here just playing something like c4
trying to find counter play somewhere
else but it's not going to be enough s
gilmore just going up a full clean piece
here by the way black was already up a
pawn
and it looks like s gilmore is in very
good position to uh to win this game
uh what else is going on let's check in
with i love legos too
uh up against murray's gp
and this one seems to be a close fight
still seems to be a close fight nobody's
up any pieces
and i like this last move by white you
know i'm i'm never really a fan uh too
much of putting your pieces on squares
where they aren't defended just makes
them really loose and vulnerable to
tactics for example if you know knight
f3 could ever be played with check
attacking the bishop on c3 it might be
good of course knight f3 in this
position though not good because the
queen can take and defend the bishop
though
so now i would hope to see something
like queen a1 and look at that it
appears on the board legos showing some
understanding here making a very strong
battery on this long diagonal this night
now is actually pinned to this bishop it
cannot move and some difficult decisions
are are heading black's way now we'll
see how maurice tries to solve these
problems with just five minutes left on
the clock
just five minutes on the clock
and audi chandra in the chat thanks for
joining adi
okay and f6 yeah i thought this move
might be might be coming but this this
move obviously really
puts your bishop in a little bit of a
box here
and while wasting no time i love legos
comes out with f4 just ready to
maul black in the center look at these
pawns coming down the board it's it's
not going to be pretty e5 i guess is is
white's idea but there's actually
another idea here in the form of f5 now
that you've induced this ugly ugly move
f6 if you can just keep that pawn on f6
keep that bishop locked in this jail
there's something to be said for that as
well so f5 is in fact what white goes
for you know i'm not entirely certain it
was correct in this instance but it was
definitely interesting c4 now coming
with discovered check on the white king
but white has such phenomenal control
over these dark squares that i can't
imagine this is giving legos too much
consternation here
so we get takes on b3
takes on b3 back and
i almost don't want to go away from this
game this game is is quite an
interesting one with legos trying to put
on a master class with the two bishops
against the knight
in the meantime taking a look at our
scores here it looks like yeah edward
jones has lost this match in the games
that they did play it looks like it's
going well for them alex kurford is the
last remaining game
up against sweet man there fishers of
men uh sweeping his opponent and it
looks like justini did come back in the
second game against dv dutch
so edward jones the players who were
here did put up a good showing but with
all those forfeits there's just no way
to uh to come back from that there's
just no way
in the meantime we saw frank tan and c
cell split their second game and yeah
let's check in on this alex kirford game
here so we have once again even material
as always it's a close fight when these
two players uh face each other in this
corporate chess league
and
well i'm i'm not entirely certain who i
would rather be here white definitely
has some trumps attacking this weak e6
pawn but in the meantime the queen side
belongs to the black pieces here this
rook can invade on whichever square it
chooses we can also see this rook maybe
going after the c pawn as well
definitely a lot to play for
so
as always a close exciting fight between
these two players let's see what alex
comes up with here yeah we get rook b3
coming in attacking the c3 pawn
and notably moves like rook e3 trying to
swing over and attack the king just not
on the table here thanks to this lovely
knight that black is posting up on f5
now if i'm white i'm looking for a way
to get rid of this knight i'm looking at
stuff like queen f4 g4 get rid of this
guy and then uh and then i can focus a
little bit more on my attack
alternatively we definitely want to be
bringing this knight into the powerful
e5 square where it can just exert its
dominance over the board but for the
moment you know black seems to be a
couple tempi ahead on his plan
that being said queen f7 strikes me as a
little bit odd i would have preferred to
see something like just rook c8 just
very very direct come after this pawn
here on c3
now you know this knight is going to be
hopping so it's hopping in knight e5 g5
all moves that's uh black is going to
have to consider very very carefully
um so a little bit of a scary position
now for black and yeah alex goes with
rook f8 and i just get the feeling that
this is the wrong direction the queen
side belongs to black but i don't think
that the f file is is the huge source of
counter play that alex is hoping
hoping it will be here and yeah now
actually i didn't even see this idea but
knight d7 and the worst has occurred for
alex kurford uh the tricky knights
strike again white now going up the
exchange will have the advantage going
into the end game here although black's
knight is still a good piece so not
without hope for black but of course
white should be winning in this position
okay with that in mind i'm seeing some
players are getting quite low on the
clock so let's check back in on desrat
against s gilmore um and deseret with
the lead on the clock gilmore with the
lead on the piece count you know last we
checked in on on this uh position
gilmore was up a piece seemingly for
nothing so uh kudos to desrat making it
interesting because this pawn on b7
really going to be giving gilmore some
some serious problems here you have to
find some way to keep this pawn from
promoting right now all that stands in
the way is this lone rook on b8 but the
white pieces are swarming rook a8 is
coming
i i guess that's the idea rook a8 is
coming um this knight might be able to
help but it might not be enough on its
own
see rook c2 by black and i really would
have preferred to see this rook land on
the d2 square believe it or not why is
that well i want to come back to the
first rank sometimes i want to just be
defending on the back row here and i'm
not going to be able to do that on the
c8 square due to this pawn so
interesting choice by gilmore down on
the clock deserot definitely needs to
find some way to keep up the pressure
keep the threats coming yeah rook a8
keep hitting the guy
now we get knight c6
and now we'll see if white can maneuver
this second rook into position
it no longer needs to defend the pawn on
b7 because the rook was pinned instead
we see a trade and i'm not a big fan of
any trade from white here you want to
keep pieces on keep it complicated keep
the pressure up until suddenly your
opponent finds himself with no time
that being said it might just tactically
be working out what is rook d1 here rook
d1 heading for the d8 square and once
again i you know i might have preferred
to have have my own rook on the d file
if i were playing with the black pieces
yeah rook d1 comes deseret finds it now
it's up to gilmore will there be a
a response here what can you do i think
black is is just gonna have to give up
this knight which is
not
not ideal in the slightest i think you
have to go something like i don't know
maybe even g5
just get checked
yeah okay so so knight
c6 actually was forced checkmate for
black instead we see or force checkmate
for white instead we see white doing the
other order going up a queen i think
more accurate was just making the queen
first allowing black to take and then
rook d8 is simply game over that's
checkmate instead though white sees the
chance to grab the king to grab the
queen
does not go for checkmate but now uh
this game still looks like it's des rats
to win and yeah
now all the black pieces just
immediately following these tactics
and that's going to be the match so huge
comeback by desrat scoring uh dardy's
first full point that's the first win
for dardy in this match impressive stuff
in the meantime the games are dwindling
here in this game between alex and
sweetman still underway and yeah the
worst has happened the worst has
happened without uh
without the extra rook
white is able to capitalize on black's
weaknesses and black is just not able to
capitalize on the c3 weakness anymore
and alex seems to be uh seems to be
busted here i'm not sure there's too
much hope in this position so
sweet man getting revenge on his rival
from edward jones
in the meantime we have i love legos 2
still fighting hard with a minute 10 on
the clock
looks like a good position for black but
at this point in this kind of time
pressure you know you can never be
certain you can never be certain and
yeah i love this move queen e3 when
you're down you want to keep pieces on
the board keep things complicated make
it so your opponent still has to think
about your threats that way they think
for too long
they're out of time and the game is
yours
see queen d3 coming now
and yeah if you're legos you just have
to keep the pressure up keep those moves
coming uh try and not blunder any pieces
but it's it's speed above all else now
and yeah queen check i love it you can
just check for days with the white
pieces now queen f5 coming and it's
honestly really tough for black to
escape these checks only 36 seconds on
the clock can he keep the pressure up
queen e6 check now where's the king
going
where is the king going what's going on
here where's the king going king h8
and i i guess yeah queen c8 the only
check now king h7
and we are repeating moves here guys
we're just repeating
i think black's gonna have to try king
f8 at this point okay so we see king f8
now king f7 and the point should be that
after queen f5 knights are beautiful
defenders of the king and knight f6
would have stopped any further checks it
said bishop f6 and now i mean now the
checks are going to keep coming the
question is
does it take wait longer to find the
checks then it takes black to escape the
checks uh whoever
moves faster here is going to be winning
okay this move was actually a bit of a
blunder due to queen b8 but it doesn't
matter it's just it's a clown fiesta now
play the moves who can play faster who's
the faster player check
and oh no lego is going down there's no
more checks
just plays king queen g4 okay
yeah now the the rolls are reversed it
looks like lego's just a little bit too
slow on that mouse definitely maurice
is the faster player in this event and
then it might not even matter because
maurice is finding checkmates so very
close battle i think this is our last
game remaining now between sweet man and
alex kirford alex down on the clock down
a queen hoping for some kind of
stalemate hoping against hope but sweet
man is is gonna be able to get it done
with two minutes on the clock here
yeah king c7 and now it's as simple as
one two and that is that is checkmate
okay with that game i believe our first
round is entirely concluded
so exciting games from round number one
just to recap here we have edward jones
i i believe if the spreadsheet is to be
trusted i believe edward jones has
officially lost their first round due to
all the forfeits if you're only counting
the games that actually got played they
actually narrowly beat worldwide
technology with fissures of men being
the hero there
sweeping his opponent however i do think
these these forfeits are going to be
counted as the players did not give
enough notice before dropping out of the
event
in the enterprise bayer matchup we had
kamikaze knight and chess hulky the uh
mainstays of the enterprise team the top
two boards once again getting it done
sweeping their opponents in straight
games um going uh both of them scoring
two points for the team and that is
enough for enterprise to win that match
up take those 20 points straight to the
bank for the grand prix and meanwhile in
our main matchup we saw ascension
clinching the match pretty early on up
against dardy
frank tan going one and a half to a half
against c cell and if i'm not wrong that
was the only draw in the entire event
this game right here
was the only game to end in a draw of
course it's a draw because white runs
out of time and black has no pieces left
and
with that we are looking forward to a
really exciting round too so i'm gonna
be going over some of those uh games we
still have up there
um to see what uh
what actually happened in some of these
games but once again we're looking
forward to a really exciting round two
it looks like adjustments are still
being made to
uh the spreadsheet pairings though so it
might take a little bit for them to sort
everything out once again those last
second dropouts not going to uh to make
things easy here tonight for edward
jones
um and especially because they are up
against their main rivals enterprise
enterprise of course with the super
strong kamikaze knight and chess hulky
leading the
okay other than that we have other
exciting matchups we have worldwide
technology taking on darty
and we have ascension taking on bayer
yeah alex says crushed not so not so
alex you split one to one with your
opponent
and uh
in the first round of course of the
games that actually were played looks
like you won the majority of them so
keeping it interesting to be sure
keeping it interesting to be sure in the
meantime let's see what happened in this
game this was a very interesting
position if i'm not mistaken it actually
arose from a weird line in the english
frank trying to play the scandinavian
against everything it looks like we saw
white getting this early uh
very nice sort of i don't know not a
blockade but pawn chain hemming in this
bishop here on h7 sort of killing that
piece
but then since then the game developed
into a very double-sided uh a battle you
know white pushing over here on the
king's side trying to get at the black
king but then for a while there it
looked like black was the one whose
attack was coming more quickly
loved this move queen c7 really would
have loved the move b5 here just
highlighting that the white pieces are
on the retreat and i think black could
have taken over the game instead the
rookie 8 now allows the white knight
back in after bishop d5 we saw oh black
actually just gave up this rook on a8
yeah definitely not advised there and
now the white pieces start entering
and okay b4 b4 huge mistake here you
want to open things up on the side of
the board where you're attacking and b4
i think just locks things down
yeah rook c7 black just trying to hold
on now knight d5
and white looks to have taken over the
game here
but as i said the clock reigns supreme
in these 10 zero matches
black with a couple pumps on the king
side as well and it looks like white was
able to clean those up
but now with only 15 seconds on the
board
or on the clock uh white was not able to
win on the board with two pawns to the
good so there it is there's your only
draw of the whole event so far really
really crazy stuff
in round
one okay now let's see what's going on
in some of these other games looks like
they are
uh close to getting underway in round
two here i don't see any more changes
being made to the pairings maybe they're
just taking a quick break before the
second round starts
oh no and adi chandra is saying goodbye
to everybody adi don't leave yet there's
a whole another round to be played we're
in it for the long haul here in the
corporate chess league hello shaylesh
thank you for joining and yeah why don't
we see what actually happened in this
game between vindy and kamikaze knight
of course we saw vindy playing this
weird opening with d3 but making the
best of it c3 and then e4 a very
sensible approach
and then yeah this knight h5 move and
vindy was just on the back foot then d4
continues to hit this bishop h6 and
knight into f4 black really looking to
just take over the dark squares here by
the way pointing out it's bishop on e2
not such a good piece either
rook to c1 and wow the knights just
invaded and captured on d3 and then
already just 15 moves into the game
vindy down to 50 seconds on the clock
that is not good enough time management
to survive in the corporate chess league
oh and
we see
gilmore
playing some bullet games in between
rounds staying fresh you'll love to see
it but anyways
this game rook c4
knight captures on b2 and okay enough of
all that it looks like round two is
underway i just wanted to point out
really quickly here that vindy did lose
on time quite early on in in this game
lost on move 20 on time so looking for
him to play a little bit more quickly
in the meantime though we are keeping an
eye on the big rivals edward jones
against enterprise edward jones of
course is your reigning champions and
here they are
with justini linguini who got off to a
rocky start 1-1 against d.v dutch of the
worldwide technology team but uh now
hoping to make his debut events
a little bit better he's got a chance to
take down the super strong chess hulky
from uh from enterprise and we'll see if
he's able to do it
so once again we're actually seeing
another benko and correct me if i'm
wrong but this is the opening that dv
dutch used in round one against justini
linguini i might be misremembering but i
think uh dv dutch crushed justini in a
benko gambit and now we see chess hulky
hoping to repeat that maybe he did some
prep in between rounds uh maybe he was
watching that dv dutch game doing some
prep for his opponent and now is is
hoping to to capitalize on the same
weaknesses in justine's repertoire
um with that being said we saw dv dutch
going for a little bit of a different
opening though we saw dv dutch going for
this rook a6 idea in the benko of course
this allows queen a8 this queen places
some nice pressure on the diagonal and
the rook helps facilitate an e6 break to
break things open attacking the center
instead though chess holkey going for a
more standard approach here uh an older
line with queen a5 and now black just
brings in the rooks to the queen side
goes for that classical benko counter
play just attacking white's queen side
using those open files to his advantage
we see the knight rerouting back to e5
now and i think we're in for a very
interesting game
on board i guess board one now for
edward jones against enterprise
in the meantime let's take a look at the
next board down we've got alex kurford
up against money ballin
alex with the black pieces once again
coming off of a tough loss against his
rival sweet man
let's see how he's doing in this game
though
and wow it looks like chriselle was in
the chat there of course chris had that
only draw of the event and he says it
took several days off of his life looked
like a stressful one to be sure to be
sure
um okay but what's going on in this alex
kirford game we've got d4 e6 c5 and it
looks like a benoni is alex's opening of
choice but it's a weird benoni alex
bringing this bishop to e7 rather than
the g7 square this has been one of those
lines that has never made the most sense
to me but i guess is technically fine
uh of course in the normal benco you're
gonna have this bishop on this nice open
diagonal it helps support your pawns in
the center
really you're fighting for those dark
squares on e7 the bishop doesn't do as
much to aid in that goal but it does
help support this d6 pawn and maybe
that's alex's idea to help slow down
some of those early attacks of the d6
pawn that white can go for in the normal
benoni by the way look to see this
bishop coming out to f6 later as well e7
is not its uh permanent home here and
i'm sure alex is looking to reroute it
later on
we see alex also bringing the the benoni
uh light squared bishop out early on
after h3 i would have actually expected
bishop takes f3 normally benoni players
not unhappy about that trade once again
it only helps to strengthen control over
these dark squares but alex has
something else in mind
he just puts more pressure on the pinned
piece with knight e5 and then he chooses
actually to keep this bishop out here on
g6 very unorthodox but we'll see how it
how it works out for him
uh white is able now to capture on e5
and i think that this should just be a
good structure for white this protected
pass pawn in the center of the board is
going to be something black has to keep
an eye on
although alex i'm sure is hoping just to
blockade this pawn very effectively
we get bishop a bishop f3 a6 a4
rook e8 which is definitely not my my
move of choice you need this knight here
on d6 to blockade this pawn exert its
influence over the e4 pawn and help
support a break in the center rookie 8
not going to get it done
but that catches us up with the current
position here and now alex probably
looking to break over here on the queen
side
come out with b5 and expand on that side
of the board
however
i really really think this knight just
belongs on the d6 square it would have
made these plans
much more effective i think on the queen
side
so things continuing to develop over
there and now let's check in on our
third uh game in the edward jones
enterprise matchup that's going to be
between fishers of men and kendalum
what do we have here oh we have a cairo
khan
with 2b4 i've never seen this move in my
life i have played a lot of kero cons in
my life
but i
i am struggling to remember a single
time anybody played b4 against me
so
new opening always learning okay d5 we
get takes takes bishop b2
and i guess this is the point for white
you just get this bishop fianchettoed
very very early
but to my eyes it just doesn't make a
lot of sense you're going to want to put
your pawn on d4 as white in these
openings
especially after exchanging
and so if your pawn is going to be on d4
why is your bishop on b2 it's just going
to be staring at your own pawn but let's
see what fishers of men had in mind here
he just continues development breaks now
with c4 uh black just calmly captures
this pawn plays b5 and fiance is his own
bishop keeping it simple we get castles
castles knight c3 knight d7 rookie one
rook c8 or c1 h6 a little slow but okay
nate back to e2
and yeah now pendulum capitalizing on
white's opening play
doubling these pawns over here on the
king's side
and you can see just how awkward uh
black has made or white has made his
position here by keeping this pawn back
here on d2 this pawn just belongs out on
the d4 square
and with this pawn back on d2
it's really tough to maneuver around
that being said you really don't want it
on d4 because you put your bishop over
here on the b2 square it's going to
cause some serious problems
so knight g3 fishers have been finding
some way to maneuver around his own pawn
but again
a little bit of a strange opening giving
him some unnecessary difficulties
oh and john b in the chat says go
moneyballin i wonder if that is one john
boyer representing uh the enterprise
team chess hulky might be joining us in
the chat okay let's check back in on
this game then uh we do see alex now
blockading the d5 pawn not with the
knight but with the bishop of course
knights are the best block haters that's
why i was really rooting for that piece
to maneuver over to the d6 square but
alex has other ideas in mind
and oh this is a nasty move by uh by
moneyball and queen b6 puts on the
pressure on this c5 pawn now and this is
not a problem that's going to be easily
solved here in fact uh i'm not seeing a
good solution for black if you play
queen c7 white's simply gonna take and
then take on c5
if you play rook c8 well then white
might just come in with this knights
play something like knight a4 and it's
getting really really difficult to uh to
keep that c5 pawn uh well defended
okay what else is going on let's check
back in on board one of this big match
up here
bishop g5
yeah very weird move by moneyball and
definitely not a fan of this one that
bishop was very well placed on e3
and now to go after this knight on f6
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
although i should point out that i think
i made a mistake in my commentary here
if i play knight a4
looks like you might have a problem on
the e4 square so maybe moneyballin
looking for the solutions to his
problems on e4 with bishop g5
uh still not a fan not gonna lie let's
check back in though on john boyer
speaking of he's up against justini
linguini
and with the black pieces here
what's going on it looks like uh
temporarily john was up this b3 pawn
chess hulky up this b3 pawn but white is
now able to recapture we're gonna have
an end game with even material
but for the moment a slightly awkward
bishop here on f8 it's gonna be tough
for for black to to make use of this
bishop um especially if if white is able
to play something like rook b8
that being said the more i'm looking the
more i think concretely black is just
going to be able to play bishop e7
bishop f6 keep an eye on this pawn and
keep everything together and it looks to
me like that is in fact
chess hulky's plan here
we do get rook b8 check but now this
knight on c3 will have to move
and yeah i'm not in love with uh with
how white has actually played this now
because this f3 pawn is is going to end
up being weak as well
and
maybe john boyer with some winning
chances here in this end game
okay let's continue looking around
though that's enough of this edward
jones enterprise match-up
uh in the meantime what is going on
let's see if i can find a player whose
game i haven't looked at yet i think
actually i've been
to pretty much everywhere but let's
check in on whittle it's
i think whittle it 3 might be the only
player remaining whose games i have not
gotten a chance to look at
let's see if we can pull it up here
i have to close some other ones here we
go whittle it
whittle it three up against oak ave
and what's the story we have a very
strange position with a bishop on h7
black looks to be almost checkmated but
for a second there with the bishop on h3
i thought maybe black had some counter
play but it looks like oak ave once
again has this under control
and again oak ave one of the strongest
board fours in the event i have to say
this guy
or girl i have no idea who they are but
whoever they are they seem to keep
cleaning up all of their opponents two
points in round one and
well on their way towards a points in
the first game of round two
so tough first game for us to look at
from little it but that's okay
alright so let's check back in then
continuing our little circuit here on
fissures of men and why don't we stay
with this game a little bit because i
think pendulum is is playing sort of
the maybe the game of the the tournament
here playing just very very solid chess
very conventional chess and meanwhile
he's just letting fishers of men step on
his own toes keep this pawn on d2 for as
long as you like it's only hampering
your queen and your other pieces in the
meantime you just see a devastating
attack starting to form over here on the
king's side of the board
that being said white takes on the d5
square now
and we'll have to see if uh
if this kingside play is is actually
heading anywhere
you know something like queen g1 looks
tempting but after king to e2 i'm not so
sure i see a follow-up if you give me
this check and just play knight e3
it looks like that is the path we're
following though
and i would be remiss if i did not
mention the most important factor in the
position might be that kendalum is down
to three minutes fishers of men staying
ahead on the clock and as always that is
going to be uh
going to be a uh
a pretty important factor here
oh and i was wrong on our usernames john
boyer of course is kamikaze knight not
chess hulky um
my mistakes so john boyer not playing uh
and all of my kind words for for chess
hulky uh
should go to
chess holkey and not john because john's
not playing am i titled i am titled but
only barely i'm a national master
national master of chess
[Music]
okay
and yeah as expected 93 and the the
attack is being beaten back now uh with
the the white pieces able now to access
the king's side
but again i mean this king's not exactly
comfortable in the center of the board
and i i think uh pendulum has very good
chances to uh to win this game that
being said gotta pick up the pace always
got to pick up the pace pendulum
um these are 10 minute games no
increment no delay you have to have to
move quickly
and actually
wait a second what's going on here
what's going on here some sort of
counter-attack on the g7 pawn uh out of
nowhere and now uh
yeah this this sometimes happens when
you get lower on the clock you know you
have a great position you feel like
you're ready to do the knockout punch
but if you just get a little bit too
impatient and
try to rush things with queen g1 check
then you might find yourself on the back
foot and
yeah with the g7 pawn falling i have to
say i think
i think fishers of men might be back in
control it's it's a strange little
fortress this king has in the center of
the board but it seems to be an
effective one for now the black piece is
not finding a way in this night
especially just being dominated by the
white pieces
uh okay
um and my producer in the studio says
bishop g5 was bishop g5 a good move and
maybe but uh i thought f4 you get queen
h5 check king e1
king e1 and takes takes bishop f6
okay maybe it was still under control
and then uh it does look like white
still gets some play there we're gonna
get bishop f6 knight f5 and
some pawns somewhere might be falling
knight h5 looks very very complicated
regardless though
the the main factor is is always going
to be the clock here we get rook g7
and uh and yeah four and a half minutes
to a minute and a half not looking good
for kendra and wait a second what just
happened i forgot to count the rooks for
a second
what is this no a simple in-between move
your rook got captured you you had to
take it back but you can't take it back
because your queen is hanging so
overworked piece here on e8 and kendalum
now finds himself down a rook
and uh down on the clock as well fishers
of men uh taking this one home even
though this pawns still stays on d2 one
of the weirdest openings i've seen
tonight
oh my god oh no okay well
kendallum gonna be getting his rook back
here if he can find queen takes g7 but
again
i still expect that fishers of men is is
in the driver's seat here with the big
time edge uh what is happening in these
games just what is happening
yeah pendulum taking that rook back but
taking too long to do so a minute is not
a lot of time
okay let's check back in with chess
hulky who was able to convert that end
game it looks like that very nice end
game that he had against justini
linguini in game one
so let's see how he's doing here in game
two
uh looks like what opening did we have
we had a french defense with an early
bishop d3
and the
uh more open style games that come from
the trade on e4
then early c4c5 and yeah this seems to
be a common thread in a lot of these
games we're looking at here today you
know i think uh our players in the
corporate chess league might be a little
bit overzealous with these center pawns
pushing this guy all the way to c5
that's going to give black access to
this d5 square that the other eyes
wouldn't have access to
and i think with that development you
know black's position isn't looking so
bad
i think here to to be sure white might
have a little bit of an edge this bishop
is just so well placed on f3
and you know development is going to be
very natural something like bishop e3
castles queen c2 even and just bringing
the rooks to the center could have been
very nice for white but yeah committing
to c5 and b4 all this stuff i'm not so
convinced so yeah knight d5 does come in
and then once again trying to show that
the pawns are overextended black stripes
with b6 opens up this b file and now you
know black's pieces are going to be
finding homes
we see a trade of those bishops now
queen a4
and yeah i see no reason why black
should be worse in this position
that being said if there is a reason
it's this a pawn but again i'm having a
hard time believing it you know the
white queen can invade the black or
sorry the black queen can invade the
black rook can invade and it's looking
like a very pleasant position now for
justini linguini
um okay what else do we have what else
do we have
um
let's check back in on alex against
moneyballin because they are coming down
to the wire here with just a minute left
on the clock
okay we get queen f4
alex looking now for some check meeting
ideas it looks like combining with this
idea of e4 of course
this move is also pressuring this g4
pawn
and what's the plan here moneyball and
you gotta keep the gotta keep the moves
flowing here if you slow down too much
you're gonna get down on the clock
and alex is nothing if not a dirty
flagger that guy will flag you in any
position
where he can so you have to be on the
lookout rook c4 an interesting idea to
try and stop it of course this bishop is
doing a nice job of defending on f2 so
we have a little bit more freedom with
the major pieces and yeah e4 as i said
is alex's idea
i think though that white should be able
to capture this pawn i don't know if
it's better with the queen or the rook
honestly i would be more tempted to take
with the rook just gives us more shelter
to run our king back to the center of
the board once again we don't have to
worry about f2 our bishop has that guy
covered but
positionally i like white but knowing
who the players are
i think alex might have the edge here as
we get into uh worse time scrambles
okay so we do see queen h2 a quick king
f1 by moneyballin showing some speed
maybe i underestimated him queen h3
check now will we block the check or run
okay moneyball and tries to keep it
simple just blocks perfectly fine except
for the fact that it's blundering your
rook
okay
all right well now it's a bullet game
well now it's a bullet game and we know
if i click on alex's name here we might
be able to see
1700 bullet player pretty good money
ballin
yeah 1 000 rated bullet player and as
expected as the clocks get low alex gets
strong so here
i'm not liking money balance chances
once you go down this rook you just have
to bang those moves out one after the
other keep the pressure up and i don't
think moneyballin is the type of player
that excels in that kind of scenario
we see queen g3 giving his king some
space is important
um but yeah now the checks start coming
and white is in a pretty grave danger
here pretty grave danger queen c4 check
king g1
and
that being said alex you know
a little faster would be good a little
faster would be good okay queen check we
see now oh
disaster has struck again for moneyball
and trying to stay ahead on the clock he
loses his queen and alex is able to get
it done a close fight nonetheless with
moneyballin but alex does prevail in the
end
and with that
um of the games played the score is 2-1
in this edward jones enterprise matchup
so really close stuff here really close
all right checking back in major
developments in the game between justini
linguine never going to get tired of
saying that and chess hulky it looks
like as expected
these pawns did prove to be a little bit
over extended you know just push them a
little bit too far
and when you do that they do become weak
justine linguini able to capitalize on
that and win those two pawns outright
now just the major pieces left will
justini be able to organize his pieces
to uh to convert this end game
i think so
i think there's actually a pretty nasty
threat here rook c4 looks tempting
but
is chess holkey trying to play rook
takes e6 is that what's happening here i
don't think it works i think white is uh
or black is just able to capture but
really devious threats coming from from
chess hulky as expected as expected here
yeah john's saying he doesn't like c5
there would have preferred bishop e3 or
castles and yeah i'm of the i'm of the
same opinion here i just think simple
development doesn't really matter how
you do it you can even play something
like queen c2 if you like
probably you should castle first
stepping out of any checks
um yeah just castles bishop b3 queen c2
rooks to the center and white has a
great position that's all you have to do
c5 is trying a little bit too hard and
now we're
suffering the consequences here for for
chess hulky
you know and as soon as i say that now
i'm looking and i'm seeing things like
rook d1 i think black has to play queen
a8s and it's just like oh the tactics
never stop
um i think queen a8 would be just enough
there though for black to to not be lost
um
defending against of course the
background threat white tries to be a
little bit more tricky of course rook d1
forces queen eight but queen eight is
not too hard to find once you see the
threat so rook b1 instead but now yeah
black just plays h6 gives the king a
flight square no back rank mate for
chess hulky
and his dv's tricks will not be enough
here today
um now if i'm white i'm trying to find
some way to swindle my way back in but
it looks like yeah more pieces are going
to come off the board black's going to
keep the pressure up and then uh
then we'll see black eventually start to
push one of these pawns but he's in no
rush
oh no and this is just the worst
possible scenario we had to take on c2
now black is just able to go for a
straight king and pawn end game with two
extra pawns king and pawn end games
always going to be
decisive here
okay
with all of that out of the way why
don't we
take uh a look one more time at this
fishers of men game uh and then we'll
take a look at some of the other games
going on in of the other matchups
it looks like yeah as expected fishers
of men was able to win with that time
advantage in game one here it looks like
we have an early queen trade and
dwight's trying to put on some pressure
here white definitely way way way ahead
on development black's pieces are just
together in a clump on these two open
files not looking great
so the question now is can white use
this extra development to make some
concrete threats win some material or
will black be able to untangle if black
can untangle it's a pretty symmetrical
position i don't think white should be
too much better
okay though let's check back in on some
of these other players let's see if i
can find
if i close some of these
out let's see what's going on in this
mjc game for worldwide technology
up against c cell 0 6 0 3. so c cell had
that heart pounding draw earlier
and now
doesn't look like a heart pounding draw
this time looks like a pin looks like a
pin and c cell is going down in this
game
by the way 500 point rating gap here so
sea salt really pulling hard for his
team really putting in the work to uh
represent on board one here not an
enviable task by any means
meanwhile let's do a quick update on
where we're actually standing here with
the results in this round we have uh so
far edward jones enterprise
two games unfortunately did have to be
forfeited for edward jones but aside
from that alex and fishers of men both
won their first game for edward jones
and chess holkey won his first game
against justini linguini
meanwhile against worldwide technology
and doherty we have uh this round one
game
or sorry game one of round two between
mjc and c cell aside from that it's
looking good for worldwide technology
two wins and a draw going down the list
and lastly in the ascension versus bayer
matchup ascension is off to a commanding
lead and i think has actually secured
the victory frank tan on board one uh
sweeping his opponent vindi and maurice
also sweeping his opponent uh nmc gin
and that's enough that's enough for a
victory
uh okay with that what's going on here
wow i look away for two seconds and an
extra bishop has turned into an extra
queen and yeah c cell throws in the
towel in this position
uh with that extra queen
so with that we have a commanding lead
for worldwide technology but a comeback
is still doable for darty they just need
three and a half out of four in the
second game here
um checking in on some other games let's
see how em stoddar is doing uh i believe
this is their corporate chess league
debut
uh and they had a rough round one but it
looks like they're off to a draw in
round two against srinivas
and that's a good result so what's going
on in this game did we have another grab
from m stoddard no he's learned from his
mistakes
no grubs in the corporate chess league
it's serious business here we are
serious businessmen doing serious
business chess
no more grubs okay instead we get uh
some kind of weird tromp it looks like
some
tight some type of trompowski i guess
knight d7 h6
very strange opening moves but the
players are getting it done here i love
this move bishop g3 so far in this event
okay well i i would love it but this
pawn on c7 is hanging but the point i'm
trying to make here
is we've seen players time and time
again running into trouble with their
loose pieces you know when you develop a
bishop out early it does tend to be
loose and a little bit vulnerable to
attack so i like the sentiment put the
bishop on a square where it's super well
defended and and is not gonna run into
trouble but of course in this position
you know free pawns are free you gotta
you gotta munch on those guys while you
can
but okay bishop g3 instead we see this
knight coming
just doing a knights tour it looks like
and wow now c4 comes out and the night
continues
um
and oh yeah well this this is just no
good this is no good queen before check
of course you you have to actually
continue your night tour here so as to
not lose material
after rook c3 we just see that the the
pieces are falling off
and black up a full rook
now white captures that free pawn on c7
and we get our current position
where white is actually just down down a
full rook so not so good
if there is one hope for white it's that
this king is currently stuck in the
center of the board
maybe you can imagine some sort of
bishop e4 bishop g6 type ideas
especially now that the queen doesn't
defend that square
but it's it's going to be really tough
going to be really tough to come back
here if you are m stutter
question from the chat how many years
have i studied chess i have studied
chess for
god i don't know it's 20 21 probably
about 12 years 11 years somewhere in
there a long time long time for me at
least
um okay
in the meantime let's get back up to our
marquee matchup as they would say on our
big broadcasts and check back in with
alex how is alex doing in game two here
uh he's off to a good start has one
point against moneyballin in that tight
time scramble he was able to pull out
the victory
now we get g5 and yeah it's another
interesting position here moneyballin
definitely holding his own against the
higher rated alex
um
this knight's going to have to retreat
and yeah moneyballin has some ideas here
these rooks are are coming in and
causing some real problems for white's
position i would not be happy if i were
alex
so uh thinking of that why don't we
stick with this game for a second
and see what's going on here see what
alex is going to come up with
in order to stop these threats
uh you could go something like knight d3
but again yeah just just rookie two and
night h5 is is not much better uh knight
h5 still rookie two i don't see a reason
not to do it and how are you defending
how are you defending you can go rook g1
but then i'm going to start shopping on
all of these pawns
yeah looks tough looks very very tough
for alex i'm not seeing the solution
not seeing the way out here
okay he does go rook g3 but now again
uh what happens if i just start taking
pawns i guess alex is gonna try to go
for some sort of attack over here oh
but yeah that's that's a bad blunder by
uh by moneyball and f4 is a nice idea
trying to get rid of this rook remove
the defender but of course this rook is
actually pinning the g pawn to the kings
this knight cannot be captured
that being said it's not totally busted
yet for black these rooks are still very
very active and are going to be causing
white some problems uh for a while here
definitely for a while
all right let's stick with it here alex
still has problems to solve you know
maybe we're going to see some really
really strange repetitions of moves with
knight d3 rookie 2 knight f4 rook f2
but uh i'm not i'm not so sure i believe
it black at any moment could just uh
decline the repetition with something
like rook d5 and
keep the game going
knight d3 and again
oh my what is this what is this knights
move backwards moneyballin knights move
backwards ugh another bad blunder and uh
alex once again with that blunder i
think is is gonna be in control
and yeah we see some very quick moves
now from moneyballin i i can feel the
tilt through the computer screen uh he
had such a good position and now it just
it hurts
it hurts to to see it slipping away to
see it slipping away like this
yeah knight d4 i mean you you had to
defend your b-pawn as well uh
i i guess moneyballin is going for some
some tricky tricks here some
sorry excuse me some some tricky ideas
of going for checkmate
oh wow oh no
alex no g4 blunder of the century
knight f3 how do you stop checkmate oh
my god
oh my goodness gracious you can't even
check because the square's defended
that's just checkmating two it's
checkmate in two
knight f3 checkmate in two and wow i'm
glad we stuck with this game
that is a bad pattern to miss here yeah
g4 just undefends this f3 square you
needed this pawn in front of your king
the knight and the rook there they're
not a lot of pieces but they're enough
for checkmate with the king stuck in the
corner
yeah of course black is just playing
rook h2 on the next move you cannot stop
it if you go rook h7 i take it
rook b6 is not possible because of pawn
takes
there's just no defense here there's no
defense for alex
yeah musty is this scripted it's not
scripted i promise i promise it's not
scripted
uh sad loss here for uh for alex
i'm very very sad and i i can't look at
that anymore i just can't look at that
and we gotta look away gotta look away
okay so what's going on in this game we
have vindy
not playing his game in the corporate
chess league it looks like he's actually
finished um he's just playing some
random game on chess.com so we'll leave
him to do that are there any other games
in progress this is the last game i
think this is the last game
um
so this is an extraordinary end then uh
to uh
to to this uh this action tonight alex
is blundering checkmate with g for you
really you hate to see those kinds of
mistakes but then again moneyball and
did have a very good position until he
had a couple bad blunders himself
rookie one alex always trying to keep it
interesting daring black
to capture this rook on e1 allowing the
white king to escape its prison but
moneyballin will not be fooled he finds
the checkmate
right there there it is
wow
and that i think concludes our games
here tonight
um let's take a quick look at how this
impacted our standings if this is all
functioning
and yeah it looks like we have a couple
really big winners tonight if this math
is accurate worldwide technology is
coming away with 42 and a half grand
prix points is that accurate is that
accurate yeah so they won against edward
jones in round one they win against
darty in round two and that makes them
the big winners tonight with 42 and a
half or wait wait wait
wait wait oh god oh no
oh no
oh that okay so that math i think is is
uh
actually no that that probably is the
correct math so they they got 40 points
for winning their matches and then i it
looks like they might have scored
22 and a half points in their individual
games with each player playing four
games tonight that might be uh
might be accurate
[Music]
so yeah the big winners tonight it looks
like worldwide technology wins both of
their matches off to a good start
enterprise wins both of their matches
and ascension wins both of their matches
is that true ascension does the clean
sweep against bayer in round two and
defeats darty in round one so yeah those
are your three big winners in the first
night of the corporate chess league here
with uh with those
three teams winning both their matches
uh there are there is plenty of time
left in the season though for uh edward
jones and bayer and doherty to make a
big comeback of course edward jones had
some logistical issues tonight i believe
and that is why they unfortunately had
to forfeit so many games of course once
they get their full roster back i expect
they're going to start winning um
on these thursday nights
so
what a start to the the corporate chess
league fall season uh i had a great time
going over all of these games and what a
finish as well with that knight f3
unstoppable checkmate by uh moneyballin
against alex so i want to thank you all
very much for joining me hopefully you
all had a great time competing here
tonight and watching these corporate
chess players duke it out on chess.com
it's always a blast
uh with that in mind my name is kill
denby and i will see you two thursdays
from now september 30th be there
you